[Applause]
if you're overwhelmed by all the dm's
instagram has figured out a way for you
now to block
selected dms bustle reports that
a new update makes it easier for you to
sort out all your messages
and get more control over whose dms you
see
so goodbye to all your exes
i told you to stop contacting me i need
to let go
and start healing
goodbye
[Music]
it's true that's how it goes if you
it's been so long i don't remember if
you need to get
cheered up after crying about your dms
that's right there's something you can
do
it's bulb planting season
and the washington post put together an
excellent guide for getting your garden
ready for the spring
the post says planting bulbs is an act
of
hope and i feel like this year well
we could all use that so take that bulb
and plant it and know that the next time
you see it again
it won't be 20 20.
now our next guest who is a woman is a
woman
who is unafraid to get messy in the name
of science
you can catch her cooking up experiments
on emily's wonder lab on netflix
and today she's here to talk about the
latest in space news
please welcome emily calendrelli
hi hi emily how are you
i'm good how are you i'm so good
and i am so excited that you're on the
show because i feel like we give a nice
yin
yang um and i want to get right in so
our first story
is if i'm honest it gets my goat a
little bit it ruffles my feathers
so nasa just announced that they're
spending 14 million dollars to get
4g cell service to the moon and while i
do hope
the moon can one day stream hulu i feel
like we've got a bunch
more urgent nuts to crack right here on
the pale blue dot
so i say hesitantly but
earth first emily i hear
i hear you what's your take though
because you're so much smarter than me
about this stuff
oh no but listen i hear what you're
saying
but what it will do is it will help us
create a sustainable human presence on
the moon and eventually
a permanent presence on mars and that's
going to help
make the human species more sustainable
it'll allow us to survive
extinction and so i would say i am
humans first because you know what a fun
fact that's not actually that fun
is that 99.9 of all the species that
have ever existed on earth have gone
extinct
and you know the difference between them
and us we have a space program
well all right sticking with the moon
the bbc reports that nasa hopes to put a
woman
on the moon in 2024 and that's going to
be the first
female to ever do the moonwalk emily
could it be you i would love that and i
think this is such a big deal
because out of all of the people who
have ever gone to space
only 11 have been women
so nasa's sending the first woman to the
moon
it's going to be for their artemis
program and
they're going to be able to make our
human presence on the moon a bit more
sustainable we're not just gonna
go to the moon gather rocks and then
come back home we're going there to stay
this time
and cbs new york reports that nasa has
landed
on an asteroid for the first time ever
and that landing
lasted 16 seconds and a robotic arm
snagged a sample and should be back here
on earth in three years time
so emily what could that asteroid does
tell us
that's leftover remnants from the early
formation
of our inner solar system so studying
that asteroid dust
will help tell us how planets form and
how
planets like the earth form so it's a
really really big deal
emily the camera wasn't on me but this
was my expression
well you know emily you're gonna make me
really think about my opinion
about making sure earth is first because
i do love space and
thank you for teaching us more about the
wonderment of the universe and by the
way
you know what if we just think that
we're here on this planet and we don't
understand to have the most expansive
horizon in thought and respect and
energy
then you know what you know what emily
universe first i love it
thank you emily thank you for helping me
be a better person please watch emily's
wonder lab on netflix